[Music]
on this Monday night earthquake ravaged
regions of turkey and Syria rattled
again
compounding the pain for people who've
already been through too much
the American president's surprise visit
to Ukraine the world stands with you the
new pledges for military aid and the
political cost
attention to online Shoppers why fewer
Merchants are offering free shipping for
returns
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us a
cruel new disaster has hit turkey and
Syria two weeks after powerful
earthquakes caused catastrophic damage
there another two have rattled the
region today
[Music]
this dash cam footage shows the moment
the ground started shaking in turkey's
Thai Province it's one of the places
that was hardest hit in the original
Quake once again people are trapped
hundreds are injured by debris from
freshly collapsed buildings and there
are more deaths Crystal command Singh
has our top story tonight
[Applause]
a haunting clanging followed by blaring
sirens
two weeks after the largest earthquake
in modern history devastated turkey and
Syria another hit
it said that it's a four no it's 6.4 but
you know
it felt like it's you know higher than
that
icky you know we hardly stood up
it was very difficult
difficult is an understatement people
panicked residents homeless and staying
in makeshift camps screamed at with
Terror some needed consoling others
medical intervention
the epicenter was in antakia the capital
of turkey's hatai province in the South
the mayor of hattai according to local
media reports said people are once again
trapped under the rubble the Quake hit
just after 8 PM local time then shortly
after another the second one smaller
registered 5.8
it felt like the ground would tear apart
the ground was shaking we were very
scared we thought the ground would tear
apart in neighboring Syria the local
rescue group The White helmets say
falling buildings injured people the
group posted on social media that more
than 130 people were hurt and that they
were working to locate victims and
transport them to hospital both
countries are still reeling from the
Quake that struck February 6 which
killed more than 46 000 people since
then some 6000 and aftershocks have been
recorded it was going to happen the
being that now those already struggling
will endure another agonizing night
wondering where their loved ones are and
if they're safe Crystal gemancing Global
News London
the new earthquakes happen to the same
day U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken wrapped up his visit to Turkey
yesterday he toured hard hit areas and
today he pledged more long-term Aid
the United States is here to support you
in your time of need and we will be by
your side for as long as it takes to
recover and to rebuild
search and rescue operations are winding
down and shifting toward urgent shelter
and reconstruction work no one's been
pulled alive from the debris since
Saturday the U.S has committed 248
million dollars in humanitarian support
now to Ukraine and the top secret visit
by U.S President Joe Biden a visit being
hailed as symbolic and a significant
Milestone ahead of the one-year
anniversary of Russia's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine this Friday
[Music]
both presidents walk through the streets
of the Ukrainian Capital as air raid
sirens rang out in a strong show of
solidarity and Defiance in the face of
Russian aggression and a war that shows
no signs of flooding up
we know that they'll be very difficult
days and weeks and years ahead
but Russia's aim was to wipe Ukraine off
the map
Putin's war of Conquest is failing
Biden announced almost half a billion
dollars in military aid for Ukraine and
fresh sanctions against Russia Redmond
Shannon reports
a morning that took so many by surprise
a U.S president in a country at War
this visit months in the planning
according to the White House with
President Joe Biden only giving the
go-ahead for the secretive trip last
Friday thank you very much for coming Mr
President had a huge moment of
supporting the Ukraine Biden is seen by
many Russians and their government as
the de facto leader of a proxy NATO war
against their country nonetheless the
White House says it gave the Putin
regime a few hours notice of the visit
to try and prevent any air strikes on
Kiev because as a president remember
I was rewarding the world that he was
going to attack it was certain of it
when American Presidents visited
Afghanistan and Iraq in Wartime they had
protection from the U.S armed forces in
Ukraine there is no direct U.S military
presence necessitating a tricky
secretive and pared down visit a 10-hour
train ride from Poland with just a
handful of staff and two journalists
sworn to secrecy
the enduring image of the day the two
leaders on a walkabout amid air raid
sirens and as Biden announced another
half a billion dollars in military aid
zielinski showed the U.S president a
plaque in his honor on Ukraine's walk of
the brave but this visit was also a very
clear symbolic message of unity to
Vladimir Putin as the anniversary of
Russia's full-scale Invasion approaches
he thought he could Outlast us
I don't think he's thinking that right
now
God knows what he's thinking I don't
think he's thinking that President Joe
Biden has now left Kiev and is in Poland
his visit there includes a meeting with
leaders of Eastern European NATO
countries and it also coincides with
Vladimir Putin's State of the Union
Address on Tuesday where he could
announce details of a new spring
offensive in Ukraine Farah Redmond
Shannon in London thank you Redmond the
U.S is by far the biggest supporter of
Ukraine's sovereignty as mentioned Biden
announced an additional 460 million
dollars to help Ukraine push back
against that ongoing Russian Onslaught
the aid includes ammunition artillery
and a Lifeline for Ukraine's energy
infrastructure that's been facing a
constant barrage of missile and drone
strikes tonight ready zucchini breaks
down the U.S contribution and the battle
for Ukrainian Independence
he's been a stabilizing force in
ensuring Ukraine has what it needs to
defend itself the Americans stand with
you and the world stands with you after
a year of unwavering support U.S
President Joe Biden's commitment to
Ukraine is unmatched with his country
allocating roughly 113 billion dollars
in Aid that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars were
going to be we're announcing with you
today and tomorrow
ammunition and weaponry are the keys to
Ukraine unlocking Victory but they have
a heavy political price tag in May of
2022 60 of American adults were in favor
of providing weapons to Ukraine in the
weeks leading up to the one-year
anniversary that number has dipped to 48
percent if Ukraine is able to make
advances in the offensive that's
expected later in the spring I think
that will encourage people to believe
that this will not go on forever uh that
Victory Is Possible and therefore
support uh continuing Aid while 11
Republicans have called for an end to
spending on Ukraine party leadership is
not on board that is essential
reinforcement for the Biden
Administration amid growing concerns
that China could become a Russian weapon
supplier any country that comes to their
age should pay a heavy price
China says its role is to urge peace and
promote talks its foreign minister is
expected to travel to Russia soon
furthering its so-called No Limits
relationship with Moscow which could
further the rift with Washington there's
no question that if China provides
lethal Aid to Russia that will hurt U.S
Chinese relations it also provides
another hurdle for this U.S president to
overcome
Reggie chakini Global News Washington
today King Charles meant Ukrainian
troops training at an undisclosed
location in the UK around twenty
thousand Ukrainian troops are being put
through an intense five-week course to
help them better prepare for combat his
majesty met around 20 soldiers and said
he's in full admiration of Ukrainian
troops being trained by British forces
for the front lines
and Global News will Air a special on
Saturday night at 7 30 to mark one year
since the full-scale Russian invasion of
Ukraine
heavy rains caused flooding and
landslides in Southeastern Brazil and
it's killed at least 36 people
more than 600 600 millimeters of rain
fell in the town of San sebastio in just
one day entire neighborhoods are
underwater hundreds have been evacuated
from their homes Brazil's president flew
over some of the hardest hit areas
Monday before meeting with local
officials Carnival festivities have been
canceled in multiple cities dozens are
still missing and the death toll is
expected to rise
North Korea is being condemned by
neighboring countries for conducting a
second ballistic missile test in the
span of three days both launches saw
weapons land near Japanese Waters
leading to Japan South Korea and the U.S
all holding air drills North Korea also
issued a warning in response to the
criticism it's received but as Mackenzie
gray explains it wasn't from leader Kim
Jong-un
North Korean State tv announcing the
latest provocation two short-range
ballistic missiles splashing down in the
Sea of Japan weapons that could be armed
with a tactical nuclear weapon
it was the second launch in three days
Saturday the hermit Kingdom blasted an
intercontinental ballistic missile
capable of hitting Canada and the U.S
but it came up well short disintegrating
mid-flight the debris Landing just 200
kilometers off Japan's northern coast
causing condemnation from the Japanese
prime minister and a call for an
emergency meeting of the U.N security
Council
the North Korean response coming not
from Kim Jong-un but his sister
threatening to make the Pacific Ocean a
firing range Kim yoo-jong viewed as a
rare rising star in a country centered
around the supreme leader
the launches widely viewed as a warning
shot as American South Korean and
Japanese forces start joint military
exercises in the region including flying
long-range supersonic bombers once again
launched a ballistic missile those
allies holding an emergency meeting to
condemn Pyongyang we call on others to
condemn this action to
take appropriate steps including the
effective enforcement of sanctions
enforcement that Canada has participated
in since 2018 by sending ships and
aircraft to patrol the Korean Coast
through operation Neon McKenzie gray
Global News
Ottawa
[Music]
boundary issues coming up why complaints
are piling up about changes to Canada's
electoral map plus flipping on free
shipping how online retailers may start
charging you to return items
Canada is on the verge of getting a new
electoral map it happens every decade
after each census new writings are added
and federal electoral boundaries are
redrawn to help reflect population
changes and in this case Alberta is
getting three new ridings bc1 and
another in Ontario more than 270
writings will also see new boundaries
the process is overseen by independent
non-partisan commissions but as our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken reports the changes aren't popular
with everyone
new democrat Daniel Blakey represents
the Northwest Winnipeg riding of Elmwood
Transcona
his writing is mostly Urban voters but
in the new map it will grow to become
more rural Blakey doesn't think that
makes sense I think it is a reasonable
goal of the redistribution process to
try and have uh Urban writings and Rural
writings without the split where where
possible but in fact the new rural part
of his riding tends to vote conservative
and that means the new riding boundaries
will make it harder for a new democrat
like Blakey to win there are lots of
writings like that across the country
right on the boundaries of cities
generally speaking those that become
more rural become more conservative and
those that become more urban tend to
lean liberal or NDP I would like to
thank the good people from Sydney
Victoria liberal Jaime Baptiste he's not
worried about losing liberal voters he's
upset the commission split up indigenous
communities in his Nova Scotia riding
the only place that was suggested that
they remove from that writing was the
largest Mickey Mouse community of 5 000
voters the community that that is my
home the commissions are supposed to
draw boundaries to keep together what
are called communities of Interest
basically groups identities that are
relevant to people it could be Urban
versus rural it could be linguistic
minorities could be racialized
minorities and so the commissions are
supposed to take those factors into
account in trying to keep communities
together MP Ed fast says that principle
has been ignored in his riding of
Abbotsford British Columbia I'm not sure
that the current proposal
fully reflects the communities of
interest that the commission is supposed
to take into account the city and riding
of Abbotsford will be split into two new
writings Abbotsford South Langley and
the huge riding of mission Matsui
Abbotsford now the commissions that are
redrawing these Maps they are not
allowed to consider how people vote but
I'll tell you the politicians do and
they say the way the writings have been
redrawn combined with the fact that
Alberta is getting three new seats well
that adds up to a new electoral playing
field likely to favor the conservatives
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
shop until you drop ahead why many
online retailers are changing their
return policies
online shopping has grown more popular
than ever since the pandemic but with
that boost came a big price tag and a
logistical headache for retailers
already some are getting rid of their
free returns policy but as Ann gaviola
explains some Canadian companies are
offering wallet-friendly green
alternatives
online shopping gone overboard with so
many retailers offering free returns
many businesses are overwhelmed a lot of
the retailers we're working with now
have you know upwards of 20 to 30
percent of their inventory and sales
getting returned back uh and so that's
really what the um the Crux of the
problem is a recent survey by shippo of
online retailers shows more than 40
percent of merchants say shipping prices
are their biggest challenge more than a
third expect that to be the case this
year as well that's LED retailers
including Abercrombie and Fitch and
Uniqlo to start charging for online
returns whether this signals the
Carefree era of free returns is coming
to an end we don't yet know but Canadian
Solutions have emerged offering more
cost-effective efficient cleaner
Solutions return bear partnered with the
bay in January to offer customers the
option to return items in centrally
located drop boxes it's just not
financially sustainable for small
businesses in Canada to match the
returns expectations that large
retailers have set Anthony Kendra saw
the need for homegrown help for small
businesses struggling to handle returns
and came up with his own solution we
match a customer that wants to return an
item with the next one in line that
wants to buy it completely removing a
shipping trip sustainable fashion
Advocates say the popularity of online
purchases and returns lead to a lot of
waste specifically in fast fashion where
the cost of inspecting and restocking an
item is high and companies benefit from
destroying Goods they don't sell if you
destroy those goods through landfill or
incineration and you can prove
destruction of those goods with a
certificate you will get a credit on
your next import Duty some say consumer
Behavior has to change too we buy sixty
percent more close today than we did 20
years ago and we only keep our clothes
for half as long as we use two so the
most important thing that we can be
doing to reduce our footprint and to be
more sustainable with our wardrobe is to
stop buying as much as we're buying
adjusting habits once they're set is
easier said than done especially when
online shopping is often so easy and
gaviola Global News Toronto
and that's global national for this
family day I'm far Nasser on behalf of
our Global News family I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
Bona Vista Newfoundland and Labrador we
love senior Canada so please keep
emailing us your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]
thank you